con el hobbit 19 avanzando en europa
muchos gobiernos se han visto obligados
a actuar y la mayoría como el de francia
decidieron apostar por incentivar la
vacunación en su caso impulsando la
vacuna de refuerzo y aplicando un
control más estricto para el pase
sanitario
para personal
la vacuna de refuerzo estará abierta
para todos los adultos mayores de 18
años 5 meses después de su última
inyección eso significa que en la
práctica 25 millones de franceses son
elegibles 6 millones de los cuales ya
han recibido su refuerzo esto es a 19
millones de franceses elegibles a los
que invitamos a vacunarse en los dos
próximos meses lección
en la misma línea la unión europea dio
luz verde a la vacunación con facer para
los niños de entre 5 y 11 años y en el
caso de los adultos anunció que el
recordatorio del inoculante será
requerido para mantener vigente su pase
sanitario
los estados miembros sólo deben aceptar
los certificados de vacunación que no
superen los 9 meses de la primera serie
de inoculación más allá de los nueve
meses el certificado de vacunación
dejará de ser reconocido en ausencia de
una dosis de refuerzo y es que la
situación epidemiológica en el
continente solo está empeorando alemania
sobrepasó la trágica de los 100.000
muertos desde el inicio de la pandemia
los hospitales de varias regiones están
contra las cuerdas por lo que el
ejecutivo plantea medidas
[Música]
no lo sé que necesitamos más
restricciones de contacto muchos países
ya han introducido medidas adicionales y
tenemos que seguir la situación muy de
cerca medio situación y en taxi
con la advertencia de la oms al respecto
es clara hasta febrero 500.000 personas
más en el continente podrían morir a
causa del virus